[Musique]
on ne fait plus attention à eux pas plus
qu'au panneau de signalisation ou au
poteau
électrique ils ornent les places de
village ils sont au pied de la mairie il
décore le chevet des
églises ces sentinelles c'est comme un
musée
invisible ouvert à tout
vent
deux ou trois fois l'an on vient y
déposer des gerbes de
[Musique]
fleurs les monuments aux morts de la
Grande Guerre ont fini par se mélanger
au
paysage à ceux de 14 on a ajouté
d'autres
plaques les morts de 40 les résistants
les déportés tous se confondent et puis
ceux
d'Indochine Algérie
d'ailleurs il reste encore un peu de
place au cas
où les pauvres soldats de l'armée morte
ont donné leur vie qu'au moins on vénère
leur
nom
pour la première fois c'est systématique
les guerriers inconnus ont le droit
d'être nommé et pas seulement les chefs
de
guerre les simples soldats les
sous-officiers et les officiers sont
logés à la même enseigne les paysans les
ouvriers les citadins les pauvres et les
riches tous les contingents d'hommes
envoyés au
feu noms inoubliables dont on ne se
souvient pas les mêmes souvent jusqu'à 6
ou 7ette fois les frères les fils les
pères les oncles les
cousins la pierre est gorgée de sang
danière à Salon de Provence de Verdin à
Pessac de nî à
Amien les héros ordinaires méritent
maintenant d'entrer dans un panthéon qui
doit se répandre partout à travers la
France
c'est de la frénésie chacune des 36000
communes veut son
monument sauf que la France est
exangue le quotidien L'Humanité se
désolera en voyant que l'Allemagne
rechigne à payer ses dommages de
guerre nous n'avons ni Pierre ni mortier
ni argent ni maçon pour construire des
choses propres à abriter les vivants
mais nous érigeons dans toutes les
localités de France et de Navar tant de
monuments qu'on pourrait bâtir une ville
avec ses matériaux
gaspillés élève-t-on des monuments à la
lèpre se désespère certains camarades de
tranché effrayé qu'on puisse glorifier
la guerre et les grandes
batailles
pourtant la majorité des associations
d'anciens combattants poussent à la
[Musique]
roue les poilus démobilisés demandent
que l'on honore les morts mais aussi les
vivants qui s'entraident et qui veulent
être récompensés pour ce qu'ils ont
fait qu'on les ou
[Musique]
pas il est vrai que les anciens
combattants sont une force avec laquelle
il faut compter c'est près de la moitié
du corps
[Musique]
électoral
seuls les grands monuments érigés sur
les de bataille le sont à l'initiative
de
l'État au contraire la charge de la
construction de tous les autres
monuments au mort revient aux
municipalités l'État se contente
d'accorder une petite subvention
elle est calculée en fonction du nombre
de soldats morts par rapport au nombre
d'habitants de la
commune
c'est insuffisant on organise des ball
payant des séances de cinématographe des
concerts des ventes de charité une
corrida même la quête dans certaines
paroisses
il n'est pas rare que la presse locale
publie le nom des bienfaiteurs et le
montant de leur dons c'est un
encouragement
[Musique]
certain
un comité est constitué spécialement
dans chaque commune pour suivre les
étapes du
projet le maire doit négocier défendre
ses préférences mais aussi obtenir
l'assentiment du plus grand nombre celui
des familles les familles des morts pour
la France comme celles des démobilisés
dont il faut éviter les
jalousies on est invité à aller voir les
plans ou la maquette à la mairie ou chez
l'épicier pour donner son avis car
l'œuvre à créer doit être l'œuvre de
tous selon l'expression du maire de
Château Neuf la
[Musique]
forêt le chantier qui s'annonce offre du
travail il incite les différents corps
de métier et les petits artisans sans
parler des intermédiaires à se disputer
le marché auprès des
municipalités terrassiers maçons carrier
fondeurs ferroners tailleur de pierre et
même architecte et sculpteur pour les
édifices plus
originaux
[Musique]
le bruit des marteaux et des ciseaux
retentit à travers le pays tout au long
des années 20 et jusqu'à la fin des
années
30 de nombreuses communes font de
l'origine locale ou département mental
des sculpteurs une condition de leur
appel
d'offre ainsi
Donzelli partisan venu d'Italie avec ses
fils qui s'est installé pour trouver du
travail dans les régions sinistré de
l'Est de la
[Musique]
France
en rendant hommage aux soldats de la
croix surmeuse et aux habitants morts
pendant la guerre le village a été
presque intégralement détruit
Donzelli utilise peut-être aussi la
pierre pour remercier le pays qu'il a
accueilli et donner libre cours à sa
gratitude envers les femmes et les
hommes de la
[Musique]
commune
ailleurs on est fier de solliciter des
célébrités de la capitale des sculpteurs
prestigieux Prix de Rome memre de
l'Académie des beauarts anciens élèves
de l'atelier de fremet de carpau de
Dalou ou de
Rodin y a-t-il eu un tel depuis les
[Musique]
cathédrales des entreprises qui
s'étaient spécialisé dans les statutes
de la République ou les bustes de
Marianne le culte des grands hommes et
des petits
se convertissent dans la production en
série de monuments au
Mor les marbreries funérair les
bronziers les fonderies offr sur
catalogue des stelles des obélisqu des
colonnes tronqué Lau palme couronne co
Gaulois
etc des effigies sortent en quantité du
même moule près de 800 exemplaires du
Poilu modèle Camu en une seule taille de
1,60 patiné imitation pierre de taille
ou imitation bronze en ciment dur
inaltérable aussi résistant que le
granit
ou pain en couleur naturelle bleu
horizon à la
demande les exemplaires produits en
série sont bien meilleur marché que les
œuvres originales
dans son premier roman Le jeune
Alexandre Vialat imagine en 1928 le
personnage d'un représentant de
commerce il y a encore plus de communes
qu' pens qui n'ont pas leur monument au
mort mais on n pas compris ce qu'il leur
faut on leur propose la France avec des
ailes la victoire avec des nich pointu
des pyramides de casqu des faisceaux de
baonnette et des tas de choses
allégoriques et l'art que je dis au mare
en le regardant bien en face ils s'en
foutent ils veulent leur poilu alors
voilà je leur fait des poilus en
série suivant les villages je leur colle
le numéro du régiment dans lequel ils
ont servi presque tous il ne voi plus
que ça dans la statue ça leur fait plus
de plaisir qu'une belle femme avec des
cheveux comme les réclames pour le
pétrolan tu fignoles les moletières les
boutons le sac la musette la grenade du
casque Servet chaud c'est du pain vendu
ils se reconnaissent ça c'est nous c'est
comme ça que nous
[Musique]
étions j'appris ainsi pourquoi les
villages sornaient inexcusablement d'une
belle floraison de poilu raide comme des
tuyaux de gouttière et pimpant comme des
mannequins si ce n'était pas un triomphe
de la sculpture c'était du moins une
victoire de la
psychologie majorité réactionnaire
j'offre le modèle numéro 4 le poilu
debout invincible
victorieux majorité rouge je préconise
le 4 bis le soldat mourant le cadavre la
guerre sans compensation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans la pierre ou la fonte on donne des
leçons d'héroïsme on met en scène
l'exaltation patriotique les tambours et
les trompettes le vieux sang
séché on ne passe pas cri les soldats au
bras attendus qui ainsi posté aurait
offert une cible
[Musique]
parfaite ultime représentation du
théâtre aux
[Musique]
armées
l'ennemi est orchant comme dans les
tranché l'ennemi ne se montre pas au
mieux un casque à pointe un casque pris
dans les
barbelés au pire un aigle immense abattu
au pied d'un
[Musique]
soldat
le temps est
suspendu le drap tombe d'un coup et la
statue
[Musique]
apparaît l'inauguration est la fête
rituelle de l'entre de
guerre
année après année les discours
s'adressent au monuments aux morts comme
au dieu protecteur de la cité
défile les corps constitués et les
enfants des
écoles le monument devient le centre
autour duquel gravite la vie
locale la victoire a lieu dans chaque
commune la République honore le
sacrifice de ses soldats la République
console ses enfants
en proclamant qu'ils ne sont pas morts
pour
rien la presse nationaliste lance une
virulante campagne en avril
1927 pour interdire l'inauguration du
monument de leevallois per
elle s'insurge que la guerre y soit
montrée comme une chose horrible
le populaire le quotidien dirigé par
Léon Bloom se félicite au contraire d'
voir un desmutinés fusillé pour
l'exemple et que soit figuré un
tirailleur des troupes d'Afrique victime
de la
colonisation au centre un soldat gazé à
l'agonie le préfet de la scène veut
réconcilier les points de
vue n'est-ce pas plutôt sa compassion
immense quiexprime le sculpteur Charles
hondi envers les tortures morales et
physiques enduré stoïquement par les
poilus au service de la patrie meurtrie
explique-t-il dans son
[Musique]
discours qu ouvrier qui attire toute la
polémique brise-t-il son
glave c'est l'une des armes de l'ennemi
ramassée sur le champ de bataille
justifie encore le
préfet la paix retrouvée n'est-il pas
temps de jeter ses
armes l'artiste hondi un ancien
combattant valeureux se défend de toute
inspiration
subversive il fut quand même bien
imprudent déplore le journal de l'Union
Nationale des Combattants d'en appeler à
l'imagination des spectateurs au risque
de prêter son œuvre à toutes les
[Musique]
interprétations
parmi les sculpteurs beaucoup étaient en
âge de partir combattre sur le front ou
de rejoindre des unités de
camouflage maintenant ils veulent
témoigner pour leurs
camarades les plus novateurs veulent
simplifier
frappé être moderne ce peut-être
simplement refuser l'allégorie ou le
style épique chercher à être
[Musique]
vrai
l'on peut lire dans le numéro de juillet
1922 du magazine Art et Décoration ce
compliment sur une statue de
meurtemoselle rien de brutal dans ce
guerrier dont la guerre n'est ni la
profession ni l'idéal il est virile sans
violence il reste alerte sous l'épaisse
capote et il garde jusque dans la boue
des tranché une élégance
[Musique]
native c'est presque toujours le soldat
qui a abandonné son élégant képi en beau
drap de l'été 1914 qui est représenté il
n'a plus sa tenue bleue et Garance d'un
rouge merveilleux pour les mitrailleuses
allemandes il porte enfin l'uniforme que
l'on sait bleu horizon et le
casqueadriant il a fallu attendre le
printemps 1915 pour que sa tête soit un
peu
[Musique]
protégée mais ne sont pas trop montrés
les bidon de pinard ou de gle ce qui
aidait pourtant les fantassins à jaillir
de la tranchée à l'attaque de celle d'en
face quelques dizaines de mètres plus
loin Benjamin Simonet est capitaine d'un
régiment d'infanterie chaque jour ou
presque il éc à sa femme depuis le début
de la guerre
ma
chérie il a fallu d'abord franchir un
terrain découvert d'environ 400 m battu
par les balles ce n'était rien encore du
point le plus dangereux un boyau d'une
centaines de mètres conduisait à la
tranchée au fond une boue épaisse dans
laquelle nous enfonçons jusqu'au genou
quel supplice ces 100 mè m'ont paru des
kilomètres
enfin nous voici arrivés jambes et pieds
trempés immondes mais eff fait couvert
d'une couche de boue collante si vous
m'aviez
vu enfin je prépare l'attaque transmet
mes ordres juste attend car bientôt
l'artillerie donna d'une façon
intense nos hommes sont assassés
bayonnett au canon dans la
tranchée malheureusement aucun gradin
préparé le talu est haut de près de 2 m
la terre
glissante je donne un coup de sifflet à
7h45 quelques braves gradés en tête
grimpent d'une centaine de mètres
aussitôt des mitrailleux ennemis
déclenchent leur tir quelques-uns
tombent près de la tranchée la plupart
gagnent un talu à 30 m de là et s'y
couche ceci parti l'élan est fini j'ai
beau supplier crier taper à coup de pied
sortir mon revolver les hommes ne
veulent pas quitter la
tranchée quelquesuns essaient je les
fait hiser par les pieds pour qu'ils
aillent plus vite à peine arrivent-il au
sommet pour prendre leur élan et courir
une balle les frappe et il retombent tué
ou
blessé la attaque est
raté toute la journée
ainsi tu comprends pourquoi hier je ne
t'ai pas
écrit
les monuments sont la manière moderne de
pratiquer
l'alchimie ils transmutent en dur la
chair il solidifie les corps par le
calcaire mais aussi le marbre blanc la
fondte ou le bronze l'aggloméra de
poudre de roche le béton
armé mais le fer à l'intérieur pe
rouillé il faut des aciers mêlé de
cuivre et c'est plus cher le granit en
Bretagne ou dans les vauges le gris rose
en Alsace la pierre de lave en
Auvergne rien ne doit provenir
d'Allemagne ni matériaux ni
main-dœuvre
les voici maintenant les sculpteurs qui
attrapent des choses
vues les monuments fixent en volume et
en relief ce que personne ne pouvait
voir loin du
[Musique]
front les sculpteurs stockent des gestes
ils cachent des souvenirs au fond de
leur
statue de même que les offensives
doivent être reconstitué pour les
actualités filmées la guerre est rejouée
par les
[Musique]
monuments
le spectacle est contemporain de
l'essort du
cinématographe le passage du muet au
[Musique]
parlant les statues sont
muettes mais elles
[Musique]
parlent
si ce jeune soldat se bouche les
oreilles c'est que la guerre en
permanence fait un bouquan de tous les
diables les statues sont toujours
dressées
[Musique]
érigé seul les bas relief gravés sur le
socle comme des vues photographiques
imprimé dans la pierre montrent que les
solda ont vécu enfoui enterré dans la
[Musique]
terre tout y est jusqu'au parapet au
panier en noosier au sac de sable
le froid le terrassement le poste de
gay l'attaque des gaz le souffle des tir
de canon l'exlosion soudaine le compte à
rebour juste avant
l'assaut quelque chose
d'implacable la guerre à l'essentiel la
vie la guerre la mort
l'attente
l'abrutissement
[Musique]
en une suite d'instantanée Gaston
brocket rend hommage à ses compagnons
d'armes il disperse des bouts de réis
entre rang l'étape
bain les Bains commerci Chalon en
Champagne samonieux ou l'hôpital du
valde grassce à
Paris Marcel Beach infirmier au 94e
régiment d'infanterie musicien dans le
civil
raconte rossé me présente Gaston Broquet
sculpteur soldat à la 7e grande
discussion sur Balzac
8 mai le bataillon stationne à l'entrée
du ravin de la houillette voie d'accès à
Bagatelle j'ai l'impression qu'en pleine
attaque c'est imprudent Rafal d'obus
juste sur nous pénétrant et fusant des
obus qui tombent à toute vitesse
tué blessé désordre je me foule la
cuisse un mort brquet le sculpteur qui
faisait ses débuts de brancardier sa
[Musique]
f de son côté Louis mofr médecin
auxiliaire consigne le même jour
nous voyons alors que l'un d'entre nous
ne s'est pas relevé c'est Gaston brquet
le
sculpteur je suis touché me dit-il je ne
peux plus
bouger apparemment il a un chrapenel
dans l'épaule et l'une de ses chaussur
est déchiré je le conf un brancardier
pour qu'il l'emmène
[Musique]
immédiatement
que dire à ceux qui n'ont jamais rien
vu Eugène Emmanuel Le Mercier combat aux
Éparges nos pertes sont
effroyables celles de l'ennemi pire
encore
cor tu ne peux pas savoir ma mère aimée
ce que l'homme peut faire contre
l'homme voici 5 jours que mes souliers
sont gras de cervelle humaine que
j'écrase des thoraxes que je rencontre
des
entrailles les hommes mangent à côté des
cadavres le régiment a été héroïque
[Musique]
le médecin auxiliaire René prieur le 25
février 1916 près de
Verdin le canon de 75 fauche tout les
bras les têtes les membres volent en
l'air je suis éclaboussé de
sang le ravin est comblé de morts qui
s'amoncelle et vers 4h écart quand je me
dégage de dessous ma tranchée des AR
je ne sais pas où je
vais je n'ai rien vu de plus
infernal j'entendrai toute ma vie le son
métallique du 75 les cris des blessés le
nombre inoui des
[Musique]
morts
Gaston Broquet toujours ose montrer ce à
quoi ressemble le cadavre tout
recroquevillé d'un simple
[Musique]
soldat
à auchochel dans le Pas de Calais comme
au Lila près de Paris le sculpteur Félix
des Ruel ne craint pas non plus de
représenter les
morts
l'un est affalé sur le ventre face
contre
terre l'autre regarde sans plus rien
voir voyez ce soldat explique à ses
administrés le maire d'une autre commune
située dans le puit de dô voyez cette
face convulsée par la douleur ce n'est
pas un héros victorieux c'est un paysan
de chez nous qui est allé jusqu'aux
limites de ce qu'on peut
souffrir ce corps affessé cette tête
penchée ce visage àamaigri ce regard qui
s'éteint cet épuisement cette grande
détresse tout cela dit au passant les
horreurs de la
guerre
certains sculpteurs sont les disciples
de Goya de Jéricho ils sont embarqués
sur le radeau de la
[Musique]
Méduse si veut échapper au réalisme
brutal au tragique aux scènes de la vie
du soldat comment concevoir une forme de
monument à la mesure de la démesure de
la
guerre à la hauteur de la mort de
[Musique]
masse comme à lion dans l'île du
souvenir certains adeptes de l'art DESCO
en appellent en dernier recours à
l'Antiquité à ces
[Musique]
mythologies
leurs sculptures sont proprement
monumentales
elle porte le poids de la
catastrophe le catafalque de la
[Musique]
guerre
mais les communes ne sont pas très
enclines à se tourner vers les courants
de l'avant-garde qu'ell juge souvent
décadent et ces artistes redoutent de
travailler sous
[Musique]
contrôle maintenant il faut refermer la
lourde porte ainsi à
[Musique]
vierson pour faire que la grande guerre
soit la der des der la dernière des
guerres il ne reste plus qu'à mobiliser
les
[Musique]
Titans
pendant qu'il travaille à la maquette en
plâtre de son grand monument Paul
Landowski tient son
journal 17 octobre
1919 rue de Valois au ministère monsieur
Moulet me demande toutes sortes de
renseignements pris du modèle prix de
l'exécution quel titre donné à mon
groupe le titre que je lui donnerai ce
sera
les fantômes mais pour la commande il ne
faut effrayer personne nous
l'appellerons les
morts 2 décembre
1921 l'ami bougl m'a donné 3h ce matin
pour la tête de l'homme à la pioche je
n'ai pas perdu ces 3
heures travailler l'après-midi au bras
droit de l'homme à la pioche avec le
drevveau je fais apparaître un morceau
de bras nu sous la Manche de la capote
déchirée
7 décembre
1921 fais mouler les mains du jeune
soldat le boek pour l'homme
fusil j'y suis je prends de plus en plus
possession de mon groupe et mon groupe
prend de plus en plus possession de
[Musique]
moi 15 novembre
1923 je simplifie de plus en plus la
présentation des fantômes quand on
arrive à une solution simple très simple
qui fait presque dire ce n'était pas
bien malin il n'y avait pas autre chose
à faire on peut être
content mais seuls les artistes peuvent
se douter du mal qu'on a eu pour arriver
à ce résultat et par quel détour on y
est
arrivé j'ai tout simplement ligé côte à
côte comme il l'était dans leur vie de
soldat comme ils le sont maintenant dans
les faosses où ils dorment les
morts il se redresse autour de ses
grands spectres la terre s'entrouvre il
réapparaissent debout un peu
incertain les yeux clos dit Paul
[Musique]
Landowski
achevé enfin en
1935 le groupe des fantômes chaque
figure de granit atteint 8 m de hauteur
orne la butte de chalemon où avait eu
lieu la seconde bataille de la Marne à
l'été
[Musique]
1918 corps sans nom nom sans corps les
disparus sont des morts qui n'ont pas
laissé de trace de leur
anéantissement des fantômes
ceux que l'on considère comme des
demi-morts n'ont aucune
sépulture ils n'en finissent pas de
RER ces morts sont d'autant plus
angoissants que l'on peut continuer
malgré tout en ver et contre tout à
espérer leur retour à la vie même
défiguré même inconscient même
amnésique les faits divers de l'époque
comme les romans en sont
peuplés
[Musique]
combien de soldats sont restés
inconnus rien que du côté français un
rapport parlementaire a évalué au
lendemain de la guerre leur nombre à
plus de
300000 mais en réalité c'est bien plus
un mort sur quat où un mort sur trois
n'a pu être
identifié comment être exact alors que
les soldats disparus ressortent encore
aujourd'hui des entrailles de la
[Musique]
terre qu'attendre
désormais maim Sart le sculpteur a perdu
un bras aux Éparges veut croire lui que
la mort est un passage vers l'au-delà le
prélude à la résurrection des
[Musique]
corps pas de symbole religieux en
principe sur les monuments pour ne pas
risquer de raviver la querelle de la
séparation de l'Église et de
l'État mais beaucoup de ruses y compris
la croix de guerre qui sert de croix de
substitution Jeanne d'c la Vierge
guerrière a été canonisée en 1920 par le
pape et puis par la
[Musique]
République de manière à peine voilée le
récit de la Passion offre un modèle
parfait il sert à évoquer à mux couvert
le martyre du soldat sa descente de
croix sa
[Musique]
déposition d'innombrables
piétas combien de mat terre de
lorossa quelque chose de sacré en oublie
le drame
abominable
[Musique]
dernière lettre d'eddouard
lieutenant au 169e régiment
d'infanterie ma chère
femme les attaques les contre-attaques
de part et d'autrre ne font que tuer les
hommes dans de telles circonstances nous
n'avons plus qu'à attendre la
mort tu embrasseras nos
enfants je te recommande de veiller à
leur éducation si possible de la leur
faire apprendre un
métier pour notre René il faut lui faire
avoir son bvet supérieur pour le faire
entrer dans l'école spéciale pour les
fils des officiers tués devant
l'ennemi en ce qui concerne ta pension
les assurances les mutuells ma solde
vois monsieur Chenet Surveillant de
travaux à la mairie de Nancy il t'aidera
à régler tout
cela quant à moi i qui vais reposer avec
mes camarades au cimetière de
Montauville j'aimerais bien être rentré
près de vous tous au cimetière de notre
village et bien ma chère femme je pense
au moment de mourir que j'ai passé 14
années heureuse avec toi au revoir ma
chère femme
embrasse bien mes pauvres
petits ton mari tué
Édouard
[Musique]
les monuments sont des mises en
abîme des
[Musique]
tombeaux connu ou inconnu
enterré dans les cimetières des champs
de
bataille reposant dans leur village où
disparu corps et âmes le mort peut
maintenant revenir à la
[Musique]
maison
celles qui n'ont jamais pu s'approcher
elles peuvent enfin arriver les jeunes
filles les jeunes femmes les marines de
guerre les épouses les veuves en noir et
les fiancé que l'on appelle les veuves
[Musique]
blanches
la famille peut voir son défunt une
dernière
fois le gisant est lavé en mais
pareil plus beau mort que
vivant comme s'il s'était éteint dans
son
lit la pierre accorde des larmes des
caresses et des étreintes que le mort
n'a jamais
reçu la pierre des monuments célèbre des
funérailles qui n'ont jamais eu
[Musique]
lieu
àodev dans leséos en guise de
pleureusees modernes à l'époque où les
femmes jouent un nouveau rôle et
réclament en vain leur droit de
vote quatre élégantes sont habillées
selon la mode des années
folles
leurs robes leurs manteaux leurs parures
leurs broderies sont taillé dans un
calcaire coloré à
l'acide il y a deux éléments qui dictent
impérieusement les grandes lignes du
monument la lumière directe du soleil et
la disposition du terrain répond le
sculpteur Paul dardé au journal
local la question de la lumière est très
importante c'est elle qui fait jouer la
perspective qui la détruit ou
l'accentue pour qu'elle ne soit pas
détruite cette perspective il faut
qu'elle possède une forte ossature une
masse qui ne soit pas déchictée par la
lumière d'où la disposition de ces
quatre figures sur lesquelles viendront
battre les rayons du
soleil ainsi
disposé l'ensemble prendra un beau
caractère
d'intimité
un côté du visage est intact comme chez
les gisants mais l'autre côté est
défiguré par
exception les gueules cassées il faut
les laisser errer dans les rues ou les
cacher dans les hôpitaux et les asiles
on ne les sculpte pas ça suffit comme ça
leur visage cubiste un amputé très
rarement
aucun cjat alors qu'il y a un million
d'invalides et d'hommes défigurés d'être
trafiqué par la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
guerre
Yvon 24 ans apprend la mort de son mari
Maurice
retour je suis
brisée il me semble que je n'ai plus de
cœur tant il est broyé dans ses fibres
les plus
intimes quand je songe aux longues
années qui s'ouvrent devant moi je suis
prise de
vertige il m'a abandonné alors que je
n'ai fait qu'entrevoir le bonheur de
notre union
du jour au lendemain j'apprends que tout
est fini sans avoir pu donner un dernier
regard à celui que j'aimais plus que
moi-même près de 7 ans plus tard Yvon
assiste à l'exhumation du corps de son
mari pour son rapatriment dans le
cimetière de sa ville de
Normandie ah si je le revoyais non pas
vivant
s'exclame-t-elle c'est de la folie d'y
songer mais seulement
intacte c'est lui
intact le jeune officier au visage de
héros qui a sculé Marcel pierre à la
faire témassé pour exauccer le vœu de sa
jeune
épouse
quand ils arrivaient en permission le
plus souvent les soldats ne pouvaient
rien raconter qu'aurait-on pu comprendre
à leurs
histoires le fracas des explosions les
poursuit leurs rêves sont des
cauchemars ils sentent un vide à la
place de leur
[Musique]
pensées nombre de ceux qui sont revenus
vivants font semblant d'être en vie
absent comme des revenants comme des
statues une part de reviendra
jamais il ne répondent pas aux
questions muet comme des
tombes les enfants portent l'empreinte
de ces
silences ils sont
[Musique]
pétrifiés les petites filles et les
petits garçons ont beau
ils sont voués à fêter les héros pour
faire oublier qu'ils sont des victimes
[Musique]
collatérales il y eu
7600000 à 1 million
d'orphelins on ne sait qui s'ajoute aux
600000 veuves aux parents aux frères aux
sœurs aux proches qui ont été
atteints
[Musique]
les monuments ne montrent pas que la
guerre ils ne font pas que célébrer les
héros les statutes contiennent
l'endurance la
résignation la colère
la
[Musique]
douleur ce sont des sarcophages pour
enfouir les
chagrins
pour continuer à se
[Musique]
souvenir pour parvenir à
oublier il y a des larmes dans les
[Musique]
choses
André pzard nous autres av qui
1918 mes amis tout cela est fini et
maintenant vous êtes mort je mgarde en
mes souvenirs et parfois je ne les
reconnais pas tellement j'ai changé
depuis
mes amis je visens encore à toute heure
avec vous et vous ne savez
pas je deviendrai vieux avec vous qui
serez
jeune je m'en veux de voir en ma
tristesse une chose qui est tellement
mienne il faudrait oublier que c'est moi
qui parle car c'est vous qui en êtes le
prix vous me rendez si triste que je ne
voudrais même pas mourir maintenant mais
restez sans plus jamais
changer car si je mourais toute cette
peine qui est votre chose serait
perdue laissez-moi dire ceci lentement
comme est lente une pensée
endolorie laissez-moi dire lentement
comme tombe ta regret de chères syllabes
meurtries adieu ma pauvre
guerre et c'est
tout
adieu ma pauvre
[Musique]
guerre